je suis nostalgique du temps d'avengers
endgame de tout ce que nous avons pu
vous produire aéro et moi l'émotion et
la passion n'avait jamais été aussi
présent aujourd'hui notre amitié est
plus forte que jamais et il est temps de
mon côté de vous remercier de remercier
aéro pour son soutien et de raviver
cette flamme marvel pour ce retour je
vous conseille d'activer la cloche et de
vous abonner
car ce n'est pas du tout la dernière
collaboration que nous allons faire tous
les deux allons nous replonger dans les
mystères de cette saga mythique avec le
film piliers des gardiens de la galaxie
3 en compagnie de vos deux gardiens des
théories du mcg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien que endgame et pour rôle de
conclure la saga cela ne lui empêche pas
d'apporter d'autres mystères puisque
évidemment ce n'est pas la fin des films
marvel et nombreux sont les personnages
qui continueront leur histoire
le cas de gamme aurait donc pour moi
ultra intéressant
rappelez-vous dans avengers endgame la
gamme aura originelle celle que nous
connaissions tous par le biais des
gardiens de la galaxie 1 et 2 a été
malheureusement tué par thanos afin
d'obtenir la pire de l'âme et comme il
nous l'a été prouvé dans endgame via
black widow qui a subi entre guillemets
le même sort nous ne pouvons ramener les
gens sacrifier pour la pierre de l'âme
vous l'aurez compris gamme aura est
morte et ceux normalement pour toujours
dans un bunker endgame une intrigue très
intéressante a fait son apparition
puisque la camorra qui accompagnait la
noce en 2014 a trahi son père adoptif et
s'est retourné aux côtés des avengers
pour l'ultime bataille grâce à nebula
néanmoins certains se demandent est bas
est ce que cette gamme aura est encore
vivante suite au claquement de doigts de
tony qui a totalement décimé l'armée de
thanos eh bien oui comme nous l'a montré
une scène coupée games aura sans valeur
de l'hommage à tony sur le champ de
bataille
cette scène a vraiment pour utilisation
de souligner que camorra est toujours
vivante
en plus de rendre hommage à tony
évidemment et il est sûr que quils va
vouloir aller la chercher
comme nous l'a prouvé la fin du film le
fait que gamme aura s'en aille juste et
que l'on en sache pas plus est une mise
en scène qui n'est pas dû au hasard
effectivement le film des gardiens 3 a
subi quelques épreuves dans sa
réalisation du au drama avec james gunn
cette mise en scène permet de dire ok
gamme oreilles toujours là mais on ne
sait pas encore ce que l'on va faire
avec elle le problème étant que jamais
nous ne retrouverons la même gamme aura
que celles des deux premiers opus cette
dernière n'a pas le même vécu que ce
soit concernant les trahisons les
moments de joie les moments d'amitié aux
corses d'amour bref ce n'est pas la même
caméra elle ne le sera jamais au vu de
la fin d une game il est évident que
l'intrigué principale du film ou du
moins celle de l'introduction sera de
retrouver gamme aura ces retrouvailles
sera très certainement lié
un élément perturbateur possiblement
externe ou bien dans le comportement de
gamme aura elle même car oui camorra est
l'une des plus grands assassins de la
galaxie et il est évident que nous
serons face à une gamme aura beaucoup
plus tard qu est méchante que ce qui
nous a été montrée jusqu'à maintenant le
problème étant que thanos n'est plus
donc plus de leader pour la guider
elle qui a toujours vécu sous
l'oppression et les ordres de son père
adoptif
pareil pour run and qui est mort dans
les gardiens de la galaxie 1 et je suis
prêt à parier qu'elle réside là la
faiblesse de gamme aura elle sera seule
et au vu des prochaines menace de la
galaxie une alliance entre la
protagoniste et le groupe des gardiens
pourrait s'effectuer
surtout si nebula les accompagnent de
plus je vois bien intrigue comme quoi
gamme aura se baladant seul se ferait
reconnaître par le clan d'ail et chats
qui voudraient lui botter le cul entre
guillemets bref
malheureusement n'oubliez jamais que la
gamme aura d'origine est morte concluant
toute l'histoire d'amour avec will c'est
une toute nouvelle gamme aura que nous
allons voir à l'écran et elle va donner
du fil à retordre aux groupes dans la
conception du film il serait intéressant
que lors de son périple gamme aura sauf
à se reconnaître à et sur des lieux où
la première gamme aura est allé afin de
mieux comprendre qui elle était dans le
futur et peut-être même plus humanisé
[Musique]
enfin je suis très heureux de vous en
parler
nous allons pouvoir traiter du cas d'
adam warlock comme vous le savez tous
les films marvel se suivent et plus
particulièrement les films traitant des
origin story et où des histoires
centrées sur des héros précis c'est par
exemple le cas avec les deux films des
gardiens et leur scène post générique le
premier teaser le second opus notamment
avec le retour de groot avec les
gardiens 2 nous retrouvons exactement ce
même procédé
et comme pour gamme aura les mystères
sans simplement mentionné afin de
laisser une grande liberté pour le
réalisateur en moment venu
personnage très attendu et futurs
piliers de l'univers cosmique du mc eu
d'après james gunn et kevin fait guy
adam warlock va faire son entrée dans le
gardien 3 c'est obligé ce dernier a été
créé par ayesha la grande prêtresse
dorée des souverains dans un but précis
faire évoluer son espèce vers la
perfection
d'où l'appellation d' adam le premier à
être parfait en quelque sorte mais
surtout se servir de lui pour une fois
de plus se venger des gardiens le
problème étant que adam est un être dit
parfait nous pourrions le comparer à
vision sur terre mais en vraiment
beaucoup plus puissant et comme dans les
comics à damas a été créé dans un but
malveillant pour un être dit parfait
cela ne présage rien de bon tout comme
le mythe de frankenstein
il est évident qu adam se retournera
contre sa créatrice ayesha qui est
xénophobe et se nourrit de vengeance et
de haine par rapport aux gardiens dans
l'intrigué
il est clair qu adam au tout début
obéira ayesha ce dernier sera comme une
sorte de nouveau nés un personnage sans
vécu qui découvrira l'univers
et comme chaque être à la naissance nous
avons besoin de repères
adam warlock sera donc très probablement
à la recherche des gardiens dans la
première partie du film avant de se
retourner
évaluant et comparant les attentions
d'ail et chats et des gardiens ce serait
comme ça qu'ils pourraient trouver les
réponses et se faire justice lui même
d'ailleurs je pense que cela
expliquerait la raison pour laquelle
tort serait potentiellement présents
mais nous allons en parler un peu plus
tard points qui à mon avis est très
intéressant à souligner et quant à la
puissance qui animera adam warlock la
pire de l'ama a été pendant longtemps
dans les comics à sa source
avant de s'en détacher dans le mc eu les
pierres ont été réduites à l'état
d'atomes dons
impossible à récupérer actuellement mais
il existe une autre solution qui
permettrait d'ailleurs de tout relier à
savoir les patries annuler axe souvenez
vous dans les gardiens de ayesha fait
appel au gardien pour protéger ses
batteries annuler axes d'une grande
bestioles qui sont nourris
le tout en échange de récupérer nebula
qui avait tenté de les voler requête
s'est également bien servi et on a fait
exploser un bon nombre à la fin du film
le truc avec ses batteries c'est
qu'elles sont rares et incroyablement
puissante je rappelle qu'elles ont quand
même réussi à détruire ego un céleste
depuis le début et je suis prêt à le
parier ayesha avait pour but de créer
adam en se servant de ses batteries
annuler axe mais suite aux nombreuses
péripéties bas les batteries ont été
volés détruites pour certaines et c'est
donc la place de la gemme de l'âme il
est quasiment sûr que ces batteries
serviront à adam
bon je sais que beaucoup s'attendent à
ce que je parle de la prise potentiel du
rôle par zac efron mais ce n'est pas
vraiment le plus intéressant dans tous
les cas les gardiens 3 servira à
introduire ce célèbre personnage très
apprécié par les réalisateurs et les
scénaristes
adam est surpuissant et aimé il va être
un pilier énorme des dix prochaines
années dans le mc u est d'ailleurs une
potentielle reste surrection de thanos
un jour lui permettrait d'obtenir la
gêne de l'âme et qui sait il est
possible qu adam pourrait ramener
camorra mais ne nous emballons pas
[Musique]
les gardiens ont beau être nombreux en
termes d euros pour un seul film
il se peut très largement qu'il soit
encore plus nous pouvons déjà nous
interroger quant à la réunification du
groupe de stars au gore dans les
ravageurs ce groupe va potentiellement
prendre la place qu'occupait
scénaristiquement young doo et son
équipage dans les deux premiers films
ce groupe est très reconnu dans les
comics et surtout a été teasé dans les
gardiens la galaxy 2 mais moi ce qui va
m'intéresser surtout aujourd'hui c'est
le rôle de thor avant le licenciement de
james gunn chez disney ce dernier avait
prévu de faire venir tort dans les
gardiens la galaxy 3 mai après son
départ il a été prévu que le film de
thor love and thunder arriverait avant
celui des gardiens ce qui a tout
chamboulé cawi du coup la situation est
inversée
ce sera donc normalement les gardiens
qui seront dans le film de temps avant
d'entamer leur troisième film donc
est-ce que thor sera finalement dans les
gardiens de la galaxie tran malgré ce
retournement est bien on ne sait pas
pour le moment le film 4 de thor sera
forcément axée sur le rôle que détient
tort en lui même je vous invite
d'ailleurs à voir les vidéos que le
brouhaha ayrault a fait sur le sujet
tort ne souhaite plus être le roi
d'asgard et a délégué le titre à
walkyrie avant de rejoindre les gardiens
également nous savons que natalie
portman sera de retour pour ce quatrième
film et deviendra mighty thor
ceux qui annoncent très clairement un
passage de flambeau entre thor et cette
nouvelle héroïne
cela signifie donc que thor tel que nous
l'avions connu basse et finit plus de
roi d'asgard d' et plus de super héros
le personnage va très certainement
devenir une sorte de vagabond en quête
de vérité et de savoir sur ses origines
et notamment aux daims son père
c'est là que les gardiens vont pouvoir
agir tort et le groupe sont déjà plus ou
moins liés suite aux événements dignes
finity war et sont pour le spectateur
les deux gros points de repères quant à
ce qu'il se passe dans la galaxie sans
compter captain marvel thor et les
gardiens vont avoir pour rôle de nous
relancer dans le milieu de l'espace et
introduire un univers plus cosmique et
pour être plus simple thor ne possède
plus de vaisseau deux coéquipiers donc
voilà à quoi vont servir les gardiens à
ventoux puisque thor à la fin d une game
essaye de prendre le leadership du
groupe au détriment de quils mais par
rapport aux films des gardiens il se
peut que thor soit tout de même présents
n'ont pas tout le long du film car ce
dernier n'a pas les mêmes désirs de
quelques kw il par exemple qui voudrait
retrouver gamme aura néanmoins tort
pourraient être utiles concernant adam
warlock et le peuple d'ail et chats il
est inutile de vous rappeler la
puissance de ce dernier et si combat il
doit y avoir contre sept entités
parfaite tort aurait potentiellement les
capacités pour l'affronter avant qu'il
ne se retourne enfin ce film clôturera
peut-être l'épopée autour de gardiens de
la galaxie et se peut très fortement que
le groupe soit divisée à la fin du film
gamme aura n'est plus et jamais nous ne
retrouverons les liens qu'elle
entretenait avec will nous savons
d'ailleurs peu de choses quant aux
origines de roquettes
groot monteith ou encore drax et il
n'est pas impossible que nous en
sachions plus et donc que leur quête
personnelle prenne fin nebula servira
également à faire revenir sa soeur mais
techniquement le personnage va pour moi
commencer à vraiment s'essouffler étant
donné qu'elle n'a plus sa soeur et que
thanos et son armée sont morts la mort
de gamme aura dans infinity ward n'était
qu'une introduction pour une potentielle
fin du groupe et il se peut que d'autres
disparitions arrive que certains
accompagneront tort à l'avenir merci du
fond du coeur d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo
cela nous fait extrêmement plaisir à
aero et moi de vous partager notre
passion à deux et on espère vraiment que
cela vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à nous
soutenir c'est très important en lâchant
votre plus beau pouces bleu et en vous
abonnant la chaîne pour ne louper aucune
de nos prochaines collaborations aller
voir également la vidéo cayrou a fait
sur le sujet et où j'apparaîtrai dedans
et envoyez lui un max d'amour allez que
le 'lion' alors soit avec vous c'était
dargaud rock et à très bientôt
[Musique]